hello everybody and welcome to the first
seminar for the fall 2020
different from what everybody was
expecting but
glad that we can somehow
carry on with life
so today we have uh dr san mamusa who is
a postdoctoral fellow at the immigration
policy lab and also the center for the
democracy development and the rule of
law both as stanford university
[Music]
salma is a political scientist and
she has a
very broad
experience living and been raised
in
several countries
and she has been studying uh social uh
cohesion both as a concept a process and
an outcome
um her work has been um
basically supported by
many
institutes and
has been also
widely fair across the media and
today she is going to present
the paper who was that was recently
published in science on social cohesion
intergroup contact and soccer imposed
isis iraq
salma will speak first but obviously if
you i mean depending on how she wants i
mean they will have the presentation and
then the
um
questions uh
time for questions she can
obviously take the questions she will be
giving the presentation and will uh if
she wants so maybe she might not see you
but you can raise your hand for
questions
so with that so i'll just leave you
great uh first thank you so much for
inviting me
i've been looking forward to this for a
while i'm really excited for the
discussion so i'll try to keep the
presentation on the shorter side
thanks ahmed for inviting me and teresa
for organizing
and thanks to jay pal and ipa for
funding this project so i'm here to
present some results on intergroup
contact and social cohesion in post-isis
iraq
i should say if you have clarifying
questions you can write them in the chat
and hopefully
one of the organizers will just read
them out to me if not you can interrupt
me if they're clarifying otherwise
hopefully we'll have plenty of time for
discussion at the end
so let me take you back to the summer of
2014
when a lot of us were horrified to see
isis take over large swaths of territory
in northern iraq and syria
that campaign involved the ethnic
cleansing of religious minorities
primarily yazidis but also smaller
numbers of muslim and christian groups
as well
hundreds of thousands of whom were
forcibly displaced basically overnight
from this orange iraqi area you can see
on the left there to the relative safety
of the green kurdish held area
many people thought that this
displacement would just last for a few
days and it was actually two to three
years before they would return
and when they did return this is what
they found
they found that their churches their
schools their homes had been all but
destroyed
these are two of the biggest churches in
the christian city of karakosh in
northern iraq
you can see the really heavy damage from
air raids
from their isis often would just torch
things and just burn them
on their way out when they were forced
out of the city
a lot of bullet holes everywhere and
these pictures are actually pretty
recent like this this place still looks
like this even though the city was
liberated uh two years ago
and they also found similar levels of
damage to their homes so on the left is
a picture i took in a house in korekosh
you can see in the top left corner there
the ac had been pried off the wall so
all the valuables were gone when they
came back like these to their houses
furniture really anything that could be
grabbed was grabbed
um and at the on the floor you can see
the beginnings of a tunnel that was uh
that had begun to be built by isis
fighters when they were being closed in
on
before giving up
and on the right is another home that i
visited also of christian residents and
in graffiti outside their house it says
the islamic state will live on
and maybe naively i asked the owners of
this house like why would you keep this
isis graffiti outside your house like
why why don't you paint over that um and
they were very adamant that they were
not going to paint over it and they
wanted to preserve
this graffiti as a testament to the
world of what had happened to them
and so this experience is very much
ingrained in the christian psyche and in
this communal identity this kind of
collective displacement experience and
this collective trauma
and because i think that the people who
live in these areas can speak for
themselves maybe better than i can
describe it i also have
a short clip um to show you and this is
ramy who was actually one of the study
participants and his mom talking about
their displacement experience speaking
to a pbs crew who covered the study
is one of thousands that fled
mother thought they would only be gone
for a few days
[Music]
so i think this shows just a tiny slice
of uh of what these people went through
and you can imagine that after this kind
of trauma of that isis occupation just
occupying your home
and just living there and you come home
and that's what you find and so that
displacement experience and that very
slow process of return
as you can imagine has really devastated
social cohesion in the area
especially between christians and
muslims so the muslims who stayed behind
are seen as being isis collaborators and
those who fled uh even those who were
themselves persecuted because they
belong to muslim minority groups
they're resented for different reasons
they're seen as encroaching on the
christian identity of these areas and
diluting that historically christian
presence
so whichever way you slice it whether
they're seen as isis collaborators or
even if they are themselves victims that
shared victimhood actually hasn't done
much to improve relations
and so this leaves us with a really
important policy problem which is how
can we build social cohesion after this
kind of violence
and we have a set of tools that
potentially can help which are which is
important given that backsliding into
violence after the physical fighting is
stopped is common and so these tools can
be categorized as institutional tools
and tools at the grassroots level very
broadly so at the institutional level
you have things like power sharing
arrangements
structural protections for minorities
and then at the grassroots level
we have programs that
try to improve everyday interactions
between individuals and from those
grassroots programs i'm focusing on one
which is intergroup contact this idea
that positive cooperative contact acro
across group lines generally improves
inter-group relations um it's thought to
reduce prejudice and build friendships
and on the whole this is something
that's gonna take a society forward
uh in terms of social cohesion
so in recent years we've had a solid
causal evidence base growing on this
question but there's still a lot that we
don't know so it seems generally
positive but a lot of open questions
remain
from those open questions we don't know
which conditions matter so what type of
contact matters
the original theory says that contact
should be cooperative and not
competitive that it should be endorsed
by communal authorities and norms and
that it should involve equal power
status between participants at least
within the context of the intervention
even if they're unequal in society and
of these conditions we really only have
good causal evidence on one
we also don't really know whether
contact can
affect real world behaviors so there's
two problems here the first is that the
vast majority of contact studies rely on
self-reported attitudes measured
directly after the intervention and so
we don't really know how robust these
effects are
and the second is that
there is an assumption that's really
core to contact theory which is that if
you improve attitudes and tolerance
toward the contact partner so the people
who come together for the intervention
that they're that this these positive
will extend to members of the out group
more broadly so you're now going to
navigate the whole world differently
you're going to treat strangers from the
out group differently not just the
people that you know and the the
thinking is that contact is trivial if
the effects are concentrated only within
the people in the intervention but this
assumption it seems really key to
understand the effectiveness of this uh
tool and it we don't really have
systematic tests between
effects toward people who are who meet
in the intervention versus more broadly
and lastly uh we don't have a lot of
evidence for good reasons on contact
after during or after conflict um for
good reasons because these obviously
these settings are hard to do work in
but also because the likelihood of
negative contact or contact experience
becoming negative
is probably higher in these settings and
we do know that negative contact
disproportionately shapes prejudice as
opposed to positive contact
and so the expectations can go either
way here you could think baseline
tolerance is pretty low so there's a lot
of room for improvement on the other
hand you might also think that prejudice
is particularly sticky in these settings
given that we do know that prejudice is
sticky among adults among those who have
been exposed to violence and when the
type of prejudice deals with ethnic or
religious identities as opposed to
prejudice toward the elderly or the
disabled for example which is easier to
shift
and all of these conditions are true in
my particular setting
so what i'm going to do or what i did do
is hold constant these optimal
conditions of contact as much as i can
so this is pretty rough but generally
this should be a positive contact
experience
via soccer and team sports naturally
meet a lot of the criteria i just
mentioned so it's cooperative you have
this equalizing effect of playing on a
team in terms of power status and the uh
the tournament the leagues were
supported by um christian leaders
and i'm going to hold constant those
conditions and then test contact in a
post-conflict setting and see whether
contact can change real world behaviors
so can contact build tolerance after war
and if so do those effects extend
outside of the intervention
and so the research question is can
contact build tolerant attitudes and
behaviors after war
and to preview the main result i found
that contact
improved everyday tolerant behaviors
toward peers so toward the guys within
the intervention but it did not
necessarily build broader social
cohesion outside of it
so for the rest of the talk i'm going to
outline the research design and then i'm
going to dive straight into the main
results
i'll discuss a couple of uh interesting
mechanisms
and then touch on potential backlash
effects which are really important in
the setting and show how i ruled those
out
and then i want to open it up actually
to get us talking in the discussion
about trying to understand this pattern
of results and the implications
um and then i'll end by discussing how
much i think the the setting generalizes
to other settings and takeaways from an
academic and policy perspective
so jumping into the research design so
the aim of the study was to build
christian tolerance toward muslims
if you are familiar with the middle east
this might seem a little bit backwards
like the broader social challenge is
uh improving christian muslim regard
toward minorities who tend to be
stigmatized and marginalized the reason
why i focus on christians for this study
is twofold the first is that
is just practical i had access to this
community through my ngo partners and
they form the majority in these study
sites
and then the second reason is that there
are anticipated benefits to building
social cohesion within displaced among
displaced people um so this seemed like
something that was worth doing and
especially given that christians are the
majority in these areas you still have
in a way this more traditional dynamic
of attitudes toward minorities
so the sample consisted of 42 uh
entirely christian soccer teams across
two study sites and so how this worked
was that i partnered with this christian
iraqi christian community organization
and uh we invited all of the teams in
the area which are almost entirely
divided by religion and we invited all
the christian teams in the area to sign
up for these leaks and we really um we
really hyped it up like these leagues
are going to be awesome and the fields
are new and there's going to be
bleachers and people in the stands and
trophies and professional referees and
new uniforms and all of that um and so
actually all of the teams who were
invited actually accepted the invitation
um and so once they were recruited they
then did a baseline survey
and based on their responses to a
baseline survey item on empathy toward
muslims i did a block randomization at
the team level so i took the team's
average response to this baseline item
on empathy
and then rank the teams and then all the
the two closest teams uh in kind of just
paired them uh one after the other and
then did this coin flip to block
randomize at the team level in that way
so this is what the treatment actually
looked like so what happens if you
randomize the treatment
uh so on the left you can see that
the control group received additional
christian players and the treatment
group received four additional muslim
players
and this holds constant the experience
of having new players added to your team
so these are pre-existing teams and they
either get new christian players or new
muslim players and these christian and
muslim players who are added are
themselves drawn from the rosters of
teams who weren't included at that first
step so they didn't respond to the
invitation
um or
they were like just a little bit outside
the geographic area or they were free
agents or they weren't associated with a
team and so we're holding constant this
experience of training with a new player
who should be somewhat on your level in
terms of skill because they're already
playing and practicing uh with team with
other teams
and so the randomization happens at
three at two levels the first is your
treatment status which is at the team
level and then uh conditional being
assigned to receive christian or muslim
players those individuals on your team
they were also randomly assigned
so this left me with four leagues um of
roughly 14 teams each across these two
study sites and the teams
trained together and they competed for a
two-month uh leak
and so they would if you add up these
training hours and the playing hours
they met maybe like two or three times a
week for about two months
um and so it was a league format so
every team played each other was like
around robin and then the teams with the
most points and advance to this knockout
stage of playing in the finals sorry
salman i just need some clarification um
so you just said okay so the
randomization of the team level is
whether or not you get christian players
or muslim players added and then you set
the conditional on that
uh the specific individuals are
randomized as well i didn't understand
okay how that
affects the research design or what kind
of influences we can make from that
um it doesn't effect three it's more
just to
have some to feel a little bit more
comfortable that these guys were being
added to the team so it's kind of part
of the treatment like who you're
actually meeting
that there's no reason to think that
like
having a muslim player having muslim
players added to your team would mean
they were systematically better for
example than the christian players um so
we get that inference from randomized
from recruiting those added guys in the
same way
so they were from these rosters of teams
who weren't included at the first level
and then just randomizing the particular
individuals like
it's not really that super important to
the research study it's just to
hopefully the distribution of skills
would be like somewhat even across the
teams and that is actually what we found
when i look at the baseline ratings of
the skill as rated by the ras
yeah
um so who are these guys
uh so the median player is 23 unemployed
not married and has a maximum of a high
school degree
in terms of inter-group attitudes they
have few to know muslim friends they
would not be willing to sell land to
muslims and they would not want to have
a muslim as a neighbor
how do they compare to the general
population of displaced christians so
here i'm comparing the study sample
their baseline responses
with a survey of of just over a thousand
displaced christians which i supervised
in the area around the same time as the
first study wave
and so it seems generally like along
these items like uh on the left here you
can see are you proud to be iraqi do you
think coexistence is possible are do you
think muslims are welcoming would you
sell land to muslims they're a little
bit they're pretty similar to the
general population if if anything
they're a little bit less tolerant um a
bit less likely to want to sell land and
feed muslims as being welcoming
um so touching back on the research
design so we have this group of guys
they're about to start these leaks so
how do i actually know if this is going
to work and how do i know more
importantly if the effects of contact
will extend off the field
so i categorize
my outcomes first there's behavioral
there's attitudinal and within the
behavioral outcomes i look at on the
field and off the field behaviors which
is supposed to roughly map on to
tolerance toward the guys who you know
and then tolerance toward muslim
strangers outside the intervention
so starting with the on the field
behaviors uh the three behaviors i
measure first how likely are you to
register for a mixed team next season
the second is whether you vote for a
muslim player who is not on your team
to receive a sportsmanship prize and
this award is really stressed as being
about sportsmanship not about skill
um and if anything it's actually
mechanistically biased in favor of
um
of uh choosing a christian player
because you can't pick someone on your
team and so the guys on the treated
teams there were like four muslims who
they couldn't select from so there's a
shorter list of muslims to pick
and lastly i look at whether you are
training with muslims six months later
after the intervention ended and those
muslims could be the guys who were
assigned to your team or could be from
the neighborhood in general the majority
who were still training with muslims six
months later were training with uh those
who were assigned to their teams
so these are my set of outcomes to
reflect kind of this internal tolerance
and moving to off the field tolerance
i capture three behaviors that should
measure
behaviors toward muslim strangers and
how comfortable you are toward muslims
you don't know outside the intervention
so the first is whether you attend a
mixed social event so this was like a
neighborhood event that was put on by
the league organizers and we made it
very clear that this was
an open invitation to everyone in the
neighborhood
and that the muslim players would be
coming but also other muslims from the
community and that they could also bring
their family and they could bring guests
and so it was very clear that
that this reflected the prospect of
meeting muslims who you didn't know
necessarily
and actually in the first study wave
this event coincided with the ramadan
fast breaking meal iftar so it was even
more salient for people that muslims
would be coming to this event to eat
and just so if you're curious what this
event actually looked like here's like a
little snippet
so dinner and uh and dancing and
traditional traditional dancing and some
other um and some other like
uh games and prizes were given out um
but it was not advertised as a league
event it was advertised as this
community event
the second behavior uh capturing off the
field behaviors is whether you patronize
a muslim-owned business in a muslim part
of town
so
can contact overcome these structural
these structural obstacles to social
cohesion things like social segregation
and so what i did was i have these
coupons and you can see a picture here
and so we gave all the players with
their unique id these coupons uh and
these coupons were valid for a
restaurant in mosul which is a
muslim-dominated city that's about a
40-minute drive from the from the study
site
and uh it was valid for three months
after the league ended and so we then
went and collected these coupons again
and then saw who actually showed up
because it was stamped with their unique
id
so are you more likely to go to this
muslim town which was actually seen as
the unofficial isis capital in iraq so
it's very much associated
psychologically speaking with
um
with i guess like muslim extremism or
generally like not very friendly toward
christians um in the minds of the
participants and then lastly do you
donate your one dollar survey
compensation to
the church or do you donate it to a
neutral ngo that serves both muslims and
christians um so some of the examples
given were like orphanages and cancer
charities versus the church
and then for attitudes i have eight
items in the survey which i measure at
baseline and at the end line um which
took place about a month after the
intervention and i used this
hierarchical clustering model to
collapse these eight items into three
indices and so i've labeled these
indices national unity so this consisted
of items like
we should treat each other as iraqis
first and
ethnic and religious boundaries are
arbitrary
the second index i label muslim blame so
how likely are you to blame these
various muslim civilian groups for
christian suffering
and then lastly would you want to have
any of these muslim groups as your
neighbor
so i'll pause in case anyone has further
questions before i dive right into the
main result
okay so diving straight into the main
results
so here i'm showing you the predicted
probabilities
adjusted covariate adjusted
for
the six outcomes i just described
so first comparing the means for
treatment and control so if we look at
the on the field outcomes first
so uh training with muslims voting for a
muslim to receive a sportsmanship award
and registering for a mixed team next
season we consistently see these um
significant positive treatment effects
and then when we move to the off the
field outcomes so do you visit this
muslim restaurant in another part of
town do you go to this mixed social
event do you donate your your
compensation to a mixed ngo as opposed
to the church
um there's not much movement there at
all
so this suggests that contact was seems
to be effective for on the field or
internal tolerance but it at least seems
to struggle in this case to generalize
to other social settings
and looking at the attitudinal results
they're not displayed here but of the
three indices i didn't see much movement
on muslim neighbor or muslim blame but i
did see this positive pretty chunky
effect of the national unity index so
these very abstract ideas about ethnic
divisions being arbitrary and the need
to treat each other as iraqis first but
when you ask about really concrete
intergroup attitudes questions like how
do you feel about muslims we don't
really see a change which again seems to
suggest that
looking at this generalized treatment of
muslims didn't really move but the guys
who you met in the intervention that
that was more malleable
so are these two classes of outcomes on
the field and off the field we see here
from this pattern there seems to be a
pattern but can we actually test these
against each other
so here's an exploratory analysis that i
did trying to answer that question
so what i did here was i
estimated
six new
average treatment effects so first i
look at the treatment effect of engaging
in at least
in one on the field behavior and then
the treatment effect for engaging on one
off the field behavior and then i test
those two against each other and then i
do the same for whether you engage in
two on the field behaviors or two off
the field test find those two ates test
those against each other
um and then do the same for all three
behaviors
so once i do that and i'm able to
actually directly compare uh the on the
field and off the field behaviors and do
this difference in difference so the two
difference and difference groups here
being first treatment and control and
the second level of differences on the
field versus off the field
um there does seem to be this pattern
that actually seems to be statistically
significant that you are contact does
actually make you
more likely to engage in
on the field as opposed to off-the-field
behavior so this pattern seems to be
like robust than just that first viewing
can i ask a question
yes can you hear me
yes
actually i have two questions on on this
aspect of the analysis first of all um
i guess
i don't really understand the way you do
the
on the field of the field a more natural
procedure would have been
you know uh maybe there is some sort of
latin factor which represents on the
field behavior you have six markers of
it and you do a factor analysis on those
and you do something similar for the
uh for the other type of behavior
and so i don't fully understand this one
or two or and why is that the most
efficient way of doing it
the other one is more substantive you
know so this is a technical suggestion
that you want you can um maybe you can
improve that the other one i i
i don't see what you're measuring with
these differences
this is probably my own
[Music]
lack of understanding of these things
but so why is it interesting to look at
the differences in in these two factors
in these two latent variables on the
field and off
yeah sure so um i think this factor
analysis i think that's also another
technique um i'm
open to exploring different ways of
getting at this question um this is kind
of a way that i came up with i'm sure
there are others uh what i think works
about this approach so just to maybe
elaborate on the motivation
so just going back to this the plot for
the main results
usually you see a plot where like let's
say you have a pattern of null results
somewhere and then result somewhere else
and we usually just leave it at that
like we see a pattern here and a pattern
here and so i wanted to take it a step
further and test those patterns against
each other to understand if they're
significant when you test them against
each other and going back to the theory
like you know why am i doing this study
one of the core motivations is to know
whether contact works just for the
people who you know like these known
contacts or does it actually have the
potential to unlock this broader
cohesion towards strangers and so it's
good to know that there's a pattern of
null results here and it seems more
effective here but to be able to test
those two things against each other i
think is
i think is provides more information for
getting at that core question of whether
effects generalize
yeah i think there's plenty of ways of
doing this
i like the idea of doing
well obviously i like it because i did
it i like the idea of classifying the
outcomes in terms of engaging in one or
more behaviors two or more just
descriptively like this
panel on the left i think it's
interesting to see
like the distribution of how many of
these outcomes people engaged in
um i think another way of doing it would
be pairwise like compare all of the
um compare all of the on-the-field
outcomes and all of the off-the-field
outcomes and compare them all against
each other without classifying them in
this way i just thought this was kind of
a neat structure to understand a little
bit descriptively what was going on
um so like you can see for all three
behaviors like very few people engage in
those like it's kind of a sanity check
that these magnitudes are going in the
same direction as we're kind of asking
more of the participants at each step um
yeah but i think there's other ways of
doing it i think factor analysis would
would work too
okay thanks
yeah thank you
um okay so uh we've we seem to see here
that contact is um effective at least
for some uh behavioral outcomes more
mixed effects for attitudes and no
effects for
off-the-field outcomes or how people are
behaving toward muslim strangers
so why could that be the case so here
are some
some some secondary analyses that i ran
mapping out what does the literature
tell us in terms of generating
expectations about mechanisms
and so two of the mechanisms that loom
really large in the contact literature
the first is that contact might provide
more information
and i don't find evidence for that so
so the treated sorry so the treatment
had no effect on uh information about
muslims and when you also break apart
the treatment effects uh by subgroup and
look at those who had like low versus
high baseline information i also don't
see anything happening there so it
doesn't seem to be
the key factor in this setting
the second mechanism in the literature
is that
contact might induce empathy
and similarly i don't find evidence for
this here either so again looking at
empathy as an outcome or whether you
look at heterogeneous treatment effects
by baseline empathy i also don't see a
difference there
i do find some evidence for two other
mechanisms so a mixture of qualitative
and quantitative evidence the first is
that having a positive experience seems
to be important
um so having being on a team that ends
up being successful seems to be
important for
amplifying treatment effects
and lastly it seems to be that contact
was changing norms around the
acceptability of contact both among
players and among residents
so i'll dive in
can i just ask you does does the
treatment affect the success of the
teams i was just waiting for this i'm
like yes alex is going to ask me if team
success is post treatment
yes please yeah is it post treatment
yeah so
on the one hand uh the treatment status
doesn't actually correlate with your
success so it doesn't seem like playing
on being on mixed teams made you play
better
um when i also rerun this analysis
looking at like a and when i instrument
for team success with baseline skill
rating of the players um i also see
similar results but yeah i think it's
kind of in a gray area like it i think
it is post-treatment in that
the actual playing together happened
post-treatment but they're uh but i
think it's kind of part of the bundle so
if you want to it's not true that they
sc that like the christian the teams
they got four extra christian players
scored more goals or one more games
had fewer penalties or whatever
yeah so actually um i don't have it in
here but in the paper i look at uh
success in three ways so first like the
number of points your team scored
secondly the uh skill rating of the
players and third was the number of
goals scored and actually on all three
of those just doing a t test between
treatment and control there doesn't seem
to be a difference
um
yeah so and actually i'll get into this
in a second so i'll just dive in now to
this team success and also these
changing norms are on contact so
starting first with this changing norms
so it seemed from this observational
evidence that at least in the very
very um
limited i guess or very
the level of just the norms around
playing with training with muslims like
actually playing soccer with people who
are not christian like this very basic
thing that didn't really used to happen
before these leagues seems to have
shifted so here's a quote from one of
the christian players saying you know
honestly before this league you would
never see muslims playing with a
christian team like this is the first
time and this is reflected in the
baseline data as well so of the total of
51 teams in the study only two of them
at baseline said that they regularly
train with muslims
um another i said when the game is over
we hug and kiss even when we lose that
was really a huge thing so these micro
gestures of just being friendly were
things that were actually not
not normalized
before we took these steps to actually
integrate the teams
and again because i think the players
can describe it better than i can a
short clip of some of the players
themselves the first guy is actually a
christian team captain and then the
other is a muslim goalkeeper
[Laughter]
so it seemed at least among the guys who
knew each other and they met and they
some friendships grew out of this in the
way in ways that would be predicted by
by the contact hypothesis
and i also have some uh suggestive
evidence of spillover effects among
local residents so here on the left you
can see a picture of a league game and
so these really drew a lot of crowds
this was also in the first wave before
we got the funding like to upgrade the
fields so just don't judge me on the
astroturf but a lot of people came out
to these like there were hundreds of
people and uh so i ran
this survey of about 150 local residents
like randomly selected and we asked them
about their exposure to the leagues
which i measured in a few ways so do you
live within walking distance of a field
um did you go to the final
game which had a lot of fanfare and tv
crews and the prize ceremony
do you have a family or friend playing
on the teams
and
how many games did you attend if you
attended games so these are obviously
completely correlational so maybe more
tolerant people actually show up to the
games but there does seem to be some
kind of positive correlation between
your exposure to the leagues and uh your
intergroup attitudes so this first plot
here so looking um first on the x-axis
uh who attended if you attended the
final game
uh there's it seems like the people who
attended had a more positive view
of the league's impact on their
community than those who didn't come to
the final and we invited everyone in the
town to show up
and then this was asked
actually three months after the final
and then the plot on the right uh just
looks at going from the i think the
second or no the first to the fourth
quartile
um
in terms of games attended
and looking at what your likelihood of
saying that you support future
intergroup programming in the town so
the examples that were given were
women's volleyball tournaments and
gardening clubs
um so again totally correlational and uh
but i think it's important that this
highlights that spillover effects and
these peripheral effects that happen
outside of the specific contact
intervention are really important if we
care about amplifying the impact beyond
just the specific people in the
intervention especially since it seems
like even among those people
it doesn't necessarily seem to be the
case that contact effects generalize so
we're trying to think like engineers how
to amplify the impact of this
intervention that only touches a very
small number of people
so moving on to team success
so i touched on this earlier but it
really seemed to be important that if
you played on a successful team and if
the muslims on your team played well
uh that this had an impact on how people
viewed the entire endeavor um and so i
got thinking about this when on the
sidelines like one guy with a christian
guy was on the bench and he saw a muslim
player on one of the teams score like a
hat trick and he just turns to the
research team or the league staff and
he's like why didn't you give us a
muslim that plays like that like instead
of you know
points like the christian guy on his
team who doesn't play like that and so
these you know effects really uh i
wouldn't say they're contingent on the
muslims on your team not sucking but
there it definitely helps to have a
similar skill level um so that you don't
build resentment
and so here i'm just uh breaking out the
effects of playing on a successful team
just among the treated group and this is
just a really simple difference in means
so again looking on the x zero and one
just means are you on a successful team
or not and i'm measuring success by
reaching the finals so did you reach the
knockout stage you were like the best in
your league
and then on the why i'm showing just the
proportion of people um on the treated
teams who did that outcome
so there seems to be this consistent
pattern um even on uh outcomes that
reflect generalized tolerance of playing
on a successful team um and this this
pretty much across the board uh when you
formalize this a little bit more like in
the covariate adjusted model you see the
same thing so it seems like the
successful teams really did have
amplified effects
sorry i think someone you you mentioned
that you also
this relates to mushfig's first question
of like what's what's going on with that
individual random assignment so this is
what's going on with that individual
urban assignment right is that
you're basically getting a random draw
of whether you got the good ones or the
bad ones
and i guess i'm interested in um
in order to understand this conditioning
so like how much of how much did the
skill of the players vary like
how much worse was the worst set of four
than the best set of four
yeah um so how i'm trying to get a skill
is like looking at the number of goals
scored by added players
and by the skill rating like how ras
rate their skill and there they seem to
be balanced but you still do have
individuals that
can end up being stars in other ways
like those two measures are obviously
imperfect so you might have like a
really good defender a really good
goalkeeper and then that wouldn't be
measured by in one of those metrics for
example
um and you and yeah so i think you do
have individual stars and maybe there's
a way
to look at people on those extremes
rather than just look at the average
level of the players who are added that
actually i think is a is a really good
idea
um yeah maybe something like goals did
as a measure for like defenders
and to look at like the star star
players and look at where they so the
top like three goal scorers what teams
they were on or something to get at more
of the extreme variation
so this relates to an important external
ability point let's hope my internet
connection holds up um so in south
africa
you know traditionally uh cricket and
rugby have been white sports especially
qriket i know well and
whereas soccer has been
primarily black sport
and the cricket board has tried hard
to integrate more and have more black
pairs come in and so they've actually
had the equivalent of affirmative action
in order to get more black bears in in
through the ranks
and that actually created a lot of
resentment because
they were on average not as good right
and there was a lot of resentment about
white players who were like
you know we try hard and we try to
um you know we practice a lot and we try
to get good and then
we don't make the teams and we don't
earn as much money that's exactly right
like people i mean one of the i think
one of the reasons why this league had
so much buy-in and such little dropout
is because we made it really competitive
and really prestigious and really
attractive and people really invested in
doing well and so regardless of the
religious background like they want to
win and so the flip side of that is that
you ha i think you have to make sure
there's some minimum level of skill um
or else you're you will get i think you
will expect backlash effects and you
will expect resentment because you're
you're like a net negative in these
people's lives and so i think it's
already i mean one of the drawbacks as
well of using pre-existing teams um is
that they have this like they're much
more tight-knit and so when you add a
new player like it's it's you already
have that risk of resentment at having
someone come in who they haven't chosen
when everyone else on their team has
they're like a tightly run machine and
they've already picked they've been
training each other they know each other
well and now you're throwing in this
random person
so that's one of the drawbacks another
way to do this study would be to
randomly construct the teams like you
actually put the teams together from
scratch where this might not be as much
of an issue potentially but then you get
that buy-in i think does this correspond
to any of allport's conditions
this like need that your person that
you're cooperating with has to be any
good at it
it seems like a new condition that
you're adding to the contact hypothesis
which is like good we should move past
all part like yes like we haven't
i don't know we haven't like tested all
four of the conditions um so i just it's
like is this a fifth one
i mean i think his original conditions
are reasonable but i think it's not like
you know the bible you know or the quran
like we don't we can move past it so i
think for any endeavor where like the
outcome matters and there's a stake in
it and it's something that's skill based
i think you have to have some minimum
amount of skill
does that map onto like having the
experience be positive i think that's
part of it but it could be something
deeper like it could be related to like
the actual outcome like success in a
more objective sense rather than just
did you have fun doing it and success
doesn't matter perfectly on to having
fun
um like maybe it's even just to show
that a successful experience is possible
like that that counters people's
stereotypes like i think it could
reflect a lot of things but yeah i mean
if we're up to me i would add if it's a
skill based venture if it's based on
meritocracy you have you should ensure a
minimum level of meritocracy or else
you're going to build resentment
um mushvik what do you think
so yeah i was wondering i'm sure you
know matt lowe's work at ubc
much better than i do so in his his
experiment was about randomly
constructing teams is that right rather
than this yes
yeah so i think he um yeah it's a
fantastic study and i like love when we
present our work side by side um yeah he
actually put the teams together and i
think in that setting you had a lot of
buy-in for other reasons like i don't
need to tell you like how much people
like cricket and he set it up to be like
very professional and so i think in some
settings it's possible and you don't
have so much this drawback of less of an
investment
um but in this setting in particular i
think people just would have like there
were there was already this amateur
leagues leagues and team structure that
was already happening and it felt a
little bit unnatural to move outside of
that and ask people to forget about
their teams and start from scratch
and it was already a very big ask in
this setting to get them to accept
having muslim players on their team
there's a lot of pushback around that so
one of the concessions was like okay we
keep the teams as they are
and then finally gautam rao's work which
was in delhi schools you know where
uh that was natural variation where
low-caste kids are i should say low-pass
like uh disadvantaged kids
were
were put in these classrooms
um i you know i would love to you know
maybe after the talk or like at some
point when you have time to write an
op-ed it would be great to get um
a sense of like in a two-pager you know
what did we learn from the combination
of all these studies
given the differences in
yeah
that's a great idea i know that j pal is
asking like me and matt are doing some
kind of like evidence round up about
contact but i think an op-ed is a great
idea um
yeah i love the row paper as well
because he he does actually look at real
world behaviors and he also looks at
academic achievement as an outcome which
i think like this all speaks to this
other question of how does diversity or
interview contact affect like success or
these like measurable attainment metrics
and i kind of touch on it here but i
it's such an important question outside
of just the standard prejudice related
outcomes um yeah that's a great idea
i'll i'm gonna i'm gonna commit myself
to doing that okay
my stephen had a question on the
challenge yeah please
it wasn't a question it was it was just
an observation that if you're trying to
make the parallel to real societies and
having pre-existing teams is a good
thing
yeah
um it's much more naturalistic
naturalistic natural
it's much less artificial that these
guys are already playing together and
then you have the drawback of maybe a
lack of generalizability or other things
or you can't really tinker in the way
that you might want but yeah i
completely agree like it was as
unintrusive as possible
i mean if i
you know we mentioned just the original
contact hypothesis as well um
so as i remember most of the tasks and
that were sort of group things like you
all push the truck together
rather than individual skills-based
things so that does seem to be a
new
new dimension
yeah i mean i'll i'll get to this a
little bit at the end in terms of um
generalizability and how we should
update but one of the key all ports uh
conditions one of the from the original
hypothesis is that the contact should be
cooperative
so it should involve some degree of
cooperation as opposed to competition so
if you play against each other you're
not going to find these effects
um which is what matlow tests very well
in his paper and then the other
condition which i never quite figured
out the actual difference uh but there's
another condition which is that you
should be working toward a common goal
so cooperation and having a common goal
are supposed to be
like two of the critical conditions
and uh you know thinking about policy
implications and other
like settings that are consequential
um you know maybe getting um refugees
and the host communities right if they
have to do a project together like
you know getting them to work together
towards like rebuilding efforts or
paying both of them to work in the same
team
these might
exactly right i mean there's no there's
nothing unique to contact that suggests
that it has to only be this like
interreligious prejudice that can be
overcome you can easily apply this to
like migrants and refugees different
kinds of refugees really any cleavage of
identity-based difference where that
identity is known by everyone in the
room um there's no reason why it
shouldn't work
and i think that's that's like the next
frontier and i know you guys have sandra
roso's presenting soon and me and her
actually have a project testing a very
similar setup in
colombia with venezuelan migrants and
like is there something different about
having newly mixed populations as
opposed to these old neighbors that i
have in my setting that's just that
essentially would change our
expectations but yeah there's really no
limits to it if i may say so myself
okay so i know i want to leave some time
for discussion so i'll just dive back in
so i explained a little bit about what
happened with the guys on the treated
teams and so now i want to touch on the
guys in the control teams so these are
guys on all christian teams can we rule
out backlash or at least large enough
backlash to be detected given my sample
size
and i want to show that that's the case
i think it's really important in these
fragile settings where you have this
higher risk of negative contact to be
very aware of
of this possibility
so the first way i rule out backlash is
looking at
team looking at games this is match
level data so matches that brought
together a mixed team with an
all-christian team versus matches that
brought together two christian teams or
two mixed teams and the idea is that we
want to rule out that
an all-christian team facing off and
competing against a mixed team that they
are more aggressive on the field
um so then that is it seems to be the
case it doesn't seem to be a difference
in the number of red cards or yellow
cards uh but if you're looking at
christian versus mixed team compared to
two christian teams or two mixed teams
uh using cards here as some kind of
rough proxy for aggression on the field
so like fouls and
bad language and that kind of thing
another way i can rule out backlash is
looking just at the control team so
these are the guys on all christian
teams and comparing their attitudes over
time so their baseline and their end
line surveys and there doesn't seem to
be much of a change it looks like kind
of a wash uh and so this is good so this
suggests that at least they didn't
become like significantly more
prejudiced over time
i can do the same for the muslim
participants as well
so obviously it's a much smaller sample
so some of this lack of precision is
just due to that but
it also seems like there wasn't like a
huge increase in their prejudice toward
christians when we look at their end
line compared to their baseline
it was there a coach who was making
consequential decisions on the field
like subs and support yes
and was was that person typically
christian
they were always christian the coaches
yeah okay so so then why not look at
outcomes like uh the number of amount of
playing time the muslims were given
versus the christians and things like
that
yeah that's a good idea we actually had
in the rules of the league like when we
briefed the coaches we said that they
had to have some kind of equal rotation
and that players had to get roughly
equal playing time so we had this like
rotating substitute so these guys were
like not in the best shape so they had
to rotate really regularly uh and it was
like a very high intensity format so
that actually turned out to not be a
problem at all like we had like
unlimited substitutions they were always
rotating
but in general i think this is a this is
a great idea um especially given the
importance of like communal leaders and
norms and endorsing the contact the
coaches are kind of one of the key
figures in all of this to make it happen
and the fact that performance didn't
actually you know there was no
significant difference in performance
actually i would say a positive
yeah
yeah
ah i lost mushvik
got lost again oh you're back
okay sorry i i was saying that like it
might have been a positive outcome
yeah
i guess it depends what your
expectations are
like if the if that if the counter
factuals that it would get much worse
and like things would just spiral out of
control then yeah it's good yeah so
maybe like a null in this case is a good
thing
um but the coaches were actually key
like
i one thing that we observed was at the
beginning when we first integrated the
teams like the christian players were
speaking their native dialect not arabic
so they purposely were like excluding
the muslim players they wouldn't really
sit next to them on the bench like the
players were feeling kind of excluded
and i was telling the research manager
like are you sure this is okay like i
feel bad for these guys he's like it's
okay just let them train give them a
week to train we'll do an orientation
and slowly you could see it
they warmed up to each other but the
coaches actually had a key intervention
which is they told their players this is
unprompted from us they said we have to
all speak arabic from now on we're
speaking arabic so that way everyone can
understand what's going on and that was
kind of a turning point for everything
else so i totally agree that um like
engaging coaches and seeing looking at
their decision making is really
consequential
um so to wrap up so we have this pattern
of results um that suggests that contact
effects are really concentrated among
people who know each other and so why
could that be the case there's a lot of
different structures you could overlay
on this result um so here are some
potential explanations
one is that it could just be too much of
an ask so it could be like after the
kind of
trauma that these people have
experienced asking them to then start
trusting muslim strangers is just a step
too far
so for example if you look at this young
man in the bottom left corner he brought
this picture um to one of the final
games of
his family member i believe was his
father who had passed away in the
fighting and this was actually quite
common like people would bring these
framed photos
and then on the right you see the same
guy like with his muslim teammate like
joking laughing like a few minutes later
and in his mind there's no
um there's no
disconnect between those two things like
you can still have the views that you
have toward muslims more broadly and the
kind of suffering that you
that you underwent is ingrained in you
but you can meet people and learn to
trust them and like them and have
friends from that group and you don't
necessarily see that link
um and so it might be that these kinds
of grassroots programs need that those
structural policy levers like things
like structural protections and like
real
uh real policy change to be combined
with this grassroots stuff to really
unlock the positive effects like if he
really felt safe going to mosul and he
felt safe going about his day-to-day
life maybe contact would have a bigger
effect
secondly it might be the case that
off-the-field behaviors are actually
difficult to compare to the on-the-field
behaviors in that they're more costly so
one advantage of this study is that i'm
testing these new set of real world
behaviors but at the same time because
they're very natural and realistic the
the drawback is that they're a little
bit less standardized so it's hard to
compare them directly so for example
going to mosul is much more of an a
bigger ask than voting for someone to
receive an award like going to mosul uh
requires driving time getting gas going
through annoying checkpoints and that
kind of thing
it might also be that
again back to my example of this young
man that the guys who you meet in the
contact setting you don't view them as
typical for whatever reason
so it kind of is baked into the theory
that in order for contact to work and
generalize outside the setting you
should see the people who you're meet
dealing with as being typical or else
you're gonna do all sorts of mental like
self-impressing
to say that they are exceptions um
so if you don't see them as typical then
why would it generalize you you don't
see these two these two groups of people
as being the same so you're not gonna
make any inferences
uh and lastly uh i find that um
within like look kind of zooming out at
all the outcomes i measure behaviors and
attitudes that the results are more
concentrated among behaviors in general
like i saw much more weak or mixed
effects on attitudes this actually
aligns with other work from
post-conflict settings like in rwanda
and between christians and muslims in
nigeria uh also looking at prejudice
production and there seems to be this
emerging very
tentatively and emerging pattern
in these difficult settings it might be
actually easier to change or soften some
behaviors rather than self-reported
attitudes which are might actually be
more difficult to shift
um or at least if we're changing
attitudes we're not doing it in a way
that we can reliably measure like
surveys are already too noisy and it's
it's made another reason why we should
move toward behaviors
so we've touched a little bit on
generalizability so just to consolidate
my thoughts on this
this was a bundle treatment in many ways
and the setting itself was very
particular
so i what did i what do i think worked
well i think it worked well that this
was apolitical i think it worked well
this was not like a series of dialogue
discussions about the conflict itself
and it was something that had absolutely
nothing to do
with
um politics or the conflict that helps
us with the first order problem of
actually getting recruiting people to
agree to an intergroup intervention a
lot of people are turned off by like
let's sit around a table and talk it out
those interventions have their place and
i think they can be powerful but if you
if you're wanting to optimize for a wide
appeal for recruitment that might not be
the best strategy
the flip side is that you know i didn't
see these changes to attitudes and in a
way it's like well why should i expect
them to change to update their political
beliefs because they didn't talk about
anything political
so that potentially might be a trade-off
to consider
um the second
condition that i think worked well here
is that this was endorsed by communal
authorities so this is one of allport's
conditions and so here you can see at
the in the pictures there um that
actually a priest was giving out the
awards and on the right is like a rather
horrifying team mascot which i did not
sign off on but he somehow made his way
into it and he's there taking a picture
with some members of the christian armed
forces in the area so these guys would
regularly show up at the games
um and i think this was really important
for
again in that first stage of getting
people to even sign up for them to know
that this was not going to be
stigmatizing and that this was fine and
the priests are there and the police are
there and and
there's no taboo against doing this
given that that taboo existed beforehand
there was no contact happening when it
came to soccer
and we talked about team success i think
success is somewhat of a proxy for a
positive experience but i think it
really mattered that in general like we
made these leagues something that people
really cared about and really enjoyed
and
listened very closely when they told us
how they wanted the leaks to look and it
helps us as researchers right people
don't drop out so it's great
and so i think this kind this
all these conditions can be generalized
to other settings and
those include things like classrooms
dorms military if you have conscription
and workplaces and there does seem to be
this
this causal evidence coming out on all
of these types of settings where they do
find positive effects of contact
so lastly um i hope that i've showed you
some causal evidence from
a difficult setting that cooperative
contact can build every day social
cohesion and improve everyday
interactions after war
it did seem to improve relations and
behaviors between friends and
acquaintances and peers who met in the
intervention but i did find that
transformative change was more difficult
so those effects did not necessarily
extend to strangers and so taking a step
back if we want like we can't do these
contact programs everywhere right so how
can we get the biggest bang for our buck
uh two potential two suggestions here
one is to look more at spillover effects
so this analysis i did at the local
resident suggests that there's something
going on with like being exposed or
there could be something going on with
being exposed on the periphery of this
contact and seeing it happen and that
being normalized and those effects uh
extending to you
so that's one one option and the other
way to amplify the effects of contact
could be pairing it with like a deeper
level deeper level policy tool so it
just might not be enough to focus only
at the grassroots level if there are
these glaring like structural
inequalities that are happening outside
of the intervention
another that i don't have on here is
also your if you have limited resources
who should you target for this kind of
intervention um obviously these guys
were all these were all guys
um
that was there were a lot of
particularities about this case that
meant that it would have been like very
difficult if not impossible to have
intergroup contact with women
um but the the upside of that is that
uh it seems at least anecdotally that
men
shape the social norms in the setting
and like they kind of decide what's okay
and what's not okay in terms of like
where what public spaces you can be in
and who you can be friends with and so
if you want your bang for your buck you
might want to target the people the
specific individuals who might have more
of an influence in that community and
then make sure you get buy-in from the
leaders as well um actually most of our
games happened on church fields like the
fields that were stuck to the churches
and the and so that was really important
um
and so i if i have one takeaway that i
want you to leave this presentation with
it's that contact has a lot of potential
but we really need to start measuring
real world behaviors to know what that
potential actually looks like and we
shouldn't necessarily take it for
granted that these effects will always
extend to strangers
and that might be okay in some settings
maybe in this very fragile setting if
you don't you can't expect to build
broader social cohesion and this
localized cohesion is enough to actually
build resilience against future shocks
to tolerance that's an open question
and so lastly going back to this like
classic literature on social capital it
seems like it might be time to
revitalize
the promise of these cross-cutting civic
organizations
which may actually have been so
promising initially because they
included this kind of inter-group
contact even though the original framers
might not have used that language and so
there's a natural bridge to be built
between those literatures
okay that's all i have and i'm really
looking forward to your
comments and feedback and i have a bunch
of contact and other prejudice reduction
experiments in the pipeline and so this
is really the time to have these
discussions so thank you
thank you very much sarma some more
questions
yeah i i have one um so this is super
interesting thank you very much
um
so um
you know this is a
this is a local majority community the
christians right interacting with the
local minority the muslims in a state
that's historically being
uh ruled by by muslims and so
so one question is is just about whether
you would expect um
things to work similarly elsewhere with
shia and sunni or muslims and christians
in areas where the local majorities and
minorities were different within
even the same state or whether you would
expect things to work very differently i
mean these may be some of the things
you've got in the pipeline i don't know
yeah so i think the power dynamics here
were kind of quirky
um i think it's another reason i didn't
have it outlined here but one reason for
this pattern of results might also be
that christians are at in the national
level at the in the national context are
persecuted and targeted
and so we do have some contact work that
shows that when you have when you're
looking at my people who belong to
minority groups contact is less
effective for them they're just
generally much more skeptical of the
whole enterprise and understandably so
and so that's where you really might
need the combination with policy tools
to get them on board in general it seems
to be easier for members of the majority
group to reduce their prejudice
it makes sense it's not as consequential
to their like existence you know it's
just kind of like oh i met this guy from
this group and he was cool okay move on
with my life like it's not so so much of
a of an intergroup threat and anxiety so
i think it just makes the task a bit
easier
so i would expect that things would be
easier if i focused on muslims as the
dominant group
in terms of other types of cleavages
like ethnic kurdish arab for example or
within muslims shiasuni
that i don't see any theoretical reason
for things to be different for for those
particular cleavages but that's
something i want to i would love to test
out and i think it's very dependent on
the is very dependent on the context who
seems to have the upper hand
does i have another
a comment more than a question or a
suggestion
i think your work is very interesting i
would like to go back for a second to
the
to your definition of outcomes and
the measurement that you the impacts
that you find
um i can see what you're trying to do i
think
and it's good to have those
questionnaires but apart from the fact
that you know some of your conclusions
might be the right for instance when you
say that there is a
a stronger
impact on behavior rather than attitudes
that could be driven by the fact that
behaviors might be easier to measure
than than attitudes yeah and so i a i
would definitely encourage you to
explore more
effective ways to extract this
information from the data like
can i put this question back to you
because this is something i've been
thinking a lot about can we ever
definitively answer the question are
behaviors easier to move than attitudes
given that they can't you can't put them
on the same is it impossible to
standardize a serious question because
it's something i know i know and i've
been thinking well the second part of my
question was going partly in that
direction so one possibility especially
during your contest
you should be
i would say easy but
feasible
is to try to design
uh some alternative measures based
on games and interactions among those
those guys
actually one of my ex-colleagues in
london
has been doing some work in palestine
where
she tried to
well she implemented some
cooperation games retaliation games
uh among palestinians around the world
um
and so you could think of you know at
the end of the football game to make
them play some
some games that are aimed at
at the measuring
corporation
propensity to retaliation that kind of
attitudes
and those might provide
because they link up directly to to be
to behavior to choices it might be able
to
get a more precise handle on attitudes
yeah i actually think that's a good
suggestion like lab games as being an
intermediate step between like real
world behaviors and attitudes like
something a little bit in the middle
that's more controlled in terms of the
measurements um
yeah but still yeah so that's a good
idea
yeah
if if you want i can put you in touch
with the person because yeah please do
okay yeah i'll follow up
alex
um thanks very much for this i you know
i i read the paper but the presentation
really just walks me through it i really
i learned a lot and i'm really grateful
to you for it
i wanna um i i think this presentation
makes me or this study makes me think
about the the
all ports conditions a little bit
differently
um and and one is this cooperation one
like you you did you you rightly pointed
out you're like i don't really
understand the difference between
cooperating and working towards a common
goal okay i agree i can't really put my
finger on the difference between that
either
we could push on it but
it also you to cooperate you need
another thing which is the ability to
cooperate like you can't cooperate with
someone you can't play soccer
and so like is it a it's a it's a funny
sub condition of of cooperation is the
capacity to do that and i think that
that's a
that may or may not have been present in
the previous context studies like
all right you're in a setting where
you're supposed to cooperate but did you
have the capacity to even do so
if it's the case that you could only
make friends with people who are good at
soccer then we've got a bigger problem
than we realized right so anyway i i
that's one of the places that we're
pushing and the other place
that you brought up in the car accidents
is like a
it's like a
weakness of the study but i don't know
that it is a weakness of the study is
to the extent to which the players
thought of the muslim player the
christian players thought of muslim
players as being typical of muslims
and like it's clear that a condition
here
for changing attitudes
is
since the attitude object is the the
conjured typical
muslim in your mind um so i wonder if in
in future studies
there's some measurement stuff that you
could be doing there like
do you think
that muhammad is typical
of muslims in your community right and
and i would have to imagine that they'd
say no right no mohammed's my friend are
you kidding right like um
so i but then are there interventions
that you could
deploy to be like
you know
your teammates are not so different from
the muslims in your community
like is there a way to explicitly draw
the links to increase this typicality
inference to people doing it's just a
suggestion for future studies this is
super interesting like
on your first point i actually think you
might be on to something
this ability to cooperate yeah is you
actually might be because
thinking about like some of the studies
that find like negative or no results on
contact with all the publication biases
we know about like some are mixed
classrooms in the us like these jigsaw
classrooms
and the other is a recent study out of
turkey looking at turkish and syrian
refugee kids in like a summer camp
together and in both of those cases in
the jig jigsaw classes they found that
the minority students like their just
their ability was lower so not their
ability but their how they performed in
the class uh was lower than their
classmates and so jigsaw puzzles means
you have to all work together to solve
something and then it didn't work well
maybe because it's
this underlying ability and the second
like the study in turkey they like the
syrian refugee kids don't speak much
turkish and so it seems like ability to
cooperate in that sense like you need to
speak a language like there are some
basic
there are some uh necessary conditions
for cooperation
players are willing to switch to arabic
for crying out loud yeah exactly yeah so
i actually think there's like there's
something to that like the ability to
cooperate as being something different
from cooperation which i think is i i
want to think about that more
on typicality i that's exactly what i've
done all my stuff in the pipeline now
i'm like okay we're adding a typicality
question in all of the end line surveys
um but more broadly
i wonder so i have this other study with
co-authors about exposure to muhammad
salla who's this egyptian egyptian
football super soccer superstar who
plays in liverpool
and in our survey experiment there among
fans of the club we found that the
priming people to really think about the
link between salah and muslims more
generally so when we remind them like he
prays he fasts his daughter's name is
mecca his wife wears a headscarf like
that was the only
thing that got people to update
positively about muslims more broadly as
opposed to telling them he's successful
or he's um
he's a really nice guy or these other
things so i think there's something to
this like stressing the link
having said that i really struggle
whether to whether you view someone as
typical is that actually endogenous to
your prejudice
like if you say oh like i have a black
friend but like oh they're not like all
the others or something like that like
but isn't your fencing off of your
friend actually endogenous to your
prejudice or is that itself like an
outcome that can be changed like i i'm
still working through that conceptually
okay
so
i think um this should be
for today if uh people want to send more
questions to salman happy to pass them
along and salman the same